le marché de l'art contemporain avisé
solidaire harman et a fait sa 16e
édition
les bénéfices de la manifestation sont
entièrement reversées à des actions
caritatives
cette année la maltraitance le handicap
et la maladie d'alzheimer nous avons
remis un chèque de 11 mille euros pour
des centres de vacances et d'accueil de
jour pour les personnes atteintes de la
maladie d'alzheimer mais aussi pour les
aidants peindre sculpteurs photographes
armanet regroupe des artistes d'horizons
différents tous viennent chercher un
contact et un échange avec le public
c'est toujours intéressant d'avoir des
opinions des idées c'est plaisant j'aime
l'humain a eu la preuve fait des
portraits animaliers
humain j'aime les changes j'aime là et
c'est ce que je recherche sur des lieux
comme ça arman est devenu un véritable
rendez-vous christophe baudin est
artiste peintre
il vient à montigny depuis dix ans
chaque année il ya des nouveautés
j'ai mes clients fidèles qui reviennent
et qui viennent voir les nouveautés qui
qui revient dans mon travail
régulièrement voilà donc j'ai un habitué
et j'ai aussi mes habitués au total ce
sont 40 artistes qui se sont réunis dont
20 % venaient pour la première fois